there he is doing the Carlton at a
flashmob Alfonso Ribeiro on his dancing
partner Witney Carson are here and first
of all welcome and I got to ask you are
you sick of that day we can we can be
honest I'm a little tired of it you know
that's probably why you know I really
wanted to be on Dancing with the Stars
and why am I here and you limped up on
the stage yes going on Explorer tell us
what's going on well we both have a lot
of injuries when I actually did the
Carleton on the show I injured my groin
no groans take a long time to heal yes
really the only answer well I mean at
first
everyone's super supportive you know
they really want everyone to do well but
at the end of the day you know this is a
competition so we sometimes people are
sneaking around picking their heads in
are they really oh yeah who's the big
spy come work there comes in our room a
lot he will come and kind of hang I can
see that well listen we are all huge
fans of yours and going back to Fresh
Prince a little bit you think we should
do that Kevin here's my question can you
still sing the theme song you know I
actually don't really know the theme
song like I know like a few of the
lyrics let's slow down I don't really
know I don't really know it let's see
West Philadelphia born and raised on the
playground is where I spent most of my
days chillin out maxin relaxin all cool
and all shootin some b-ball outside of
the school when a couple of guys then
we're up to no good started makin
trouble in the neighborhood I got in one
little fight my mom got scared and said
you're movin with your auntie and uncle
in bel-air
are you I mean it helped to have it up
there well you know of course we can't
like to go without seeing what you're
gonna be doing on Monday show yeah but
we're doing the foxtrot it was America's
choice
so we asked America some of the moves
that we wanted to be able to do in this
dance they chose this move so we're
gonna show you what that move America
Joe yes okay getting alright so I'll do
this side I guess right oh so you ready
let me tell you what I think you go yeah
a little sorry it first movie thanks for
coming by good luck you know no time no
time to heal